una donna decide di non seguire le leggi
razziali del tempo e di sedersi nelle
ultime file di un autobus e con la sola
forza della passione per i diritti
inalienabili della persona di tutte le
persone
contribuisce a cambiare la storia di un
intero paese
si chiamava Rosa Parks
un giovane palleggia con un pallone e
mezzo rotto su un campo di polvere di
una delle tante favelas di Buenos Aires
spalleggiando arriverà ad avere il mondo
fra i suoi piedi perché anche spenti
riflettori la sua passione stava tutta
lì
in quella palla
si chiamava Diego Armando Maradona
un giovane indisciplinato lascia
l'università per inseguire la sua
passione per l'informatica Chiama
raccolta amici e parenti per risparmiare
sulla manodopera e nel garage dei suoi
genitori assembla un primo computer si
chiamava Steve Jobs e da quel garage ha
fatto nascere Apple
questi sono solo alcune delle tante
storie di passione che hanno saputo
cambiare il mondo perché questo è quello
che la passione fa cambia il mondo
ed è per questo che penso che le vite di
ognuno di noi meritino essere vissute
con passione
sono qui oggi a svelarvi Il segreto
della passione
contenuto proprio in questa busta
Ma che cos'è la passione per me
personalmente diversamente da quello che
molti possono pensare passione è
l'obiettivo il fine e azione è il mezzo
con il quale raggiungiamo i nostri
obiettivi gli stessi ambiziosi obiettivi
che Rosa Parks Diego Armando Maradona o
Steve Jobs avevano dentro di loro per
loro la passione è stata quella luce che
ha permesso di illuminare il cammino da
lontano per renderlo più chiaro più
raggiungibile Ai loro occhi è stata poi
il carburante senza il quale
probabilmente non avrebbero mai avuto la
forza di fare quello che hanno fatto
ed è stata la loro linfa vitale
come per le piante la linfa non basta
All'inizio di un processo Ma va
continuamente cercata e prodotta lungo
tutto il percorso e non si autoproduce
per questo bisogna tenere in
considerazione la fatica a cui si può
andare incontro quando si vuole
mantenere quella passione quella linfa
costante viva e ben definita
Ma perché passione come primo
ingrediente essenziale
perché ciò che produce resilienza
autodeterminazione è quel mezzo che ti
porta a fare qualcosa quando niente
nessun altro ti danno quello stimolo
materiale economico emotivo di cui hai
bisogno
Steve Jobs Se ci pensate non aveva nulla
se non la sua passione
la passione l'ha portata ad arrivare lì
dove non avrebbe mai immaginato di poter
usare gli ha dato la convinzione la
forza di un destino meno scontato
la passione Poi ci permette di fare
delle scelte ogni giorno siamo portati a
fare delle scelte più o meno importanti
e spesso ci troviamo in difficoltà
perché non sappiamo cosa scegliere
perché vogliamo fare la scelta migliore
ma non sappiamo quale questa scelta
migliore sia anticipatamente e Quindi
spendiamo sin troppo del nostro
preziosissimo tempo nel maremoto
dell'indecisione valutiamo e rivalutiamo
ogni singolo opzione sperando che il
tempo ci dia la soluzione
il tempo
io sono così è da sempre un Eterno
indeciso anche quando si tratta di
ordinare al ristorante però ho capito
che il tempo spesso la soluzione non ce
la dà
la passione può darcela la passione mi
ha permesso di diventare più auto
cosciente di fare delle scelte molto più
consce e soprattutto più veloci perché
se ci pensate se scegliamo qualcosa che
pensiamo possiamo portare a termine con
passione allora poi il processo di
azione risulta molto più semplice e
spontaneo perché senza passione Da chi e
da cosa siamo motivati a fare una
determinata scelta
molti di voi al giorno d'oggi potrebbero
pensare al denaro e tornaconto economico
e tornaconto materiale ma siamo
veramente sicuri che i soldi
diano la stessa soddisfazione
ho 19 anni ho ancora una vita davanti
non penso di essere la persona adatta a
dare a nessuno una lezione di vita però
una definizione una risposta a questa
domanda Almeno parziale L'ho già trovata
negli ultimi tre anni di liceo ho deciso
di candidarmi rappresentante d'Istituto
perché era un ruolo che mi appassionava
mi interessava sono stato eletto ogni
anno e puntualmente ricevevo sempre la
stessa domanda
Perché lo fai
perdi solo tempo fai fatica per nulla
non ci guadagni nulla
personalmente mi sono spesso riposto
queste domande soprattutto nei momenti
più difficili quando pensavo che niente
nessuno fossero dalla mia parte ho messo
in particolare evidenza il tema del
guadagno
Cosa vuol dire guadagnarci quando fai
qualcosa con passione di certo Rosa
Parks non aveva fatto quel suo primo
gesto con l'obiettivo di guadagnarci O
forse sì non ci ha guadagnato 100
milioni di dollari Sicuramente ma una
riforma dei diritti umani
Cosa vale di più
la risposta a questa domanda potrebbe
essere ed è effettivamente abbastanza
scontata ma anche quando si trattava di
capire perché avessi deciso di
candidarmi per tre anni di seguito
rappresentante d'istituto del mio liceo
la risposta non era poi così difficile
quello era ciò che mi appassionava
e oggi ha quasi un anno dalla fine del
mio ultimo mandato sto a rispondere a
quelle persone che mi chiedevano cosa ci
hai guadagnato
una scuola migliore una comunità
scolastica più unita contenta quanto
meno soddisfatta della gestione del
proprio liceo i sorrisi degli studenti
delle studentesse grazie In corridoio
siamo le tue fan numero uno su Instagram
Sì anche quello
perché questo è quello che la passione
fa ti spinge e ti porta a fare quello
che nessun altro farebbe
ti fa apprezzare la riconoscenza altrui
come il più grande regalo la più bella
ricompensa che tu possa ricevere
non è facilmente quantificabile per
questo spesso molto più grande di
qualsiasi cifra sei zeri
Ok Ora tocca a voi
prendete le vostre passioni le vostre
vere passioni contatele
se sono più di 5 non possono essere
passioni non possono esserle tutte
perlomeno perché le passioni vi prendono
e vi portano con sé vi mettono in gioco
al 100% e non vi molla non Se provate ad
allontanarvi da loro tornano è un
circolo vizioso
Sì le passioni possono essere e sono un
circolo vizioso per questo bisogna
saperne avere a che fare bisogna saperle
curare
Non a caso una delle prime definizioni
della parola passione che potete trovare
su un qualsiasi vocabolario anche se
parzialmente legata Comunque al campo
religioso è qualcosa del genere
patimento dolore fisico provocato da
malattia o da atto violento contro la
persona
passione Anche questo
per questo bisogna saper avere a che
fare con le passioni bisogna saperle
abbracciare senza perdersi in esse senza
diventare dipendenti di passione è
difficile per questo bisogna saperne
prendere consapevolezza prima
quando mi chiedono dico sempre che
preferisco concentrarmi su un'idea un
progetto un obiettivo di vita massimo
due alla volta ma non per lentezza o per
incapacità di gestire moli importanti di
lavoro ma perché così so che posso
mettere passione e non solo azione in
quello che faccio so che posso riempire
la tanica di ciascun progetto con tutto
il carburante necessario soprattutto con
quello giusto perché ogni progetto ha
bisogno del proprio carburante
esattamente come ogni auto deve essere
rifornita col carburante adatto e poi
non ci sono così tanti tipi di
carburante diverso per questo bisogna
saper usare quei pochi Per quelli idee e
progetti obiettivi che pensiamo valgano
veramente la pena
Ecco il segreto della passione vi siete
proprio in tutto ciò nel carburante che
usiamo nella linfa vitale che riusciamo
a produrre nella fiamma che riusciamo ad
accendere nelle scelte che facciamo
è un grandissimo scrittore che mi ha
sempre affascinato è riuscito a
racchiudere l'essenza della passione in
una semplice potentissima frase
Il suo nome è Antoine de saint-exupéry
e oggi ho portato qui con me in questa
busta la sua frase
Il piccolo principe scrisse
è il tempo che tu hai perduto per la tua
rosa che ha reso la tua rosa così
importante
Il piccolo principe ci ha messo passione
Qual era la sua passione far diventare
quella rosa a cui tanto teneva unica
Ecco quindi la passione come obiettivo è
l'azione quella del prendersene cura
come mezzo per raggiungere il suo
obiettivo per rendere quella rosa così
importante
prendete un'ultima volta le vostre
passioni
a quante
dedichereste il tempo che il piccolo
principe ha dedicato alla sua rosa
Il piccolo principe ne aveva una di rosa
è vero forse perché dedicarsi a più Rose
allo stesso tempo Non le rende poi così
uniche con le passioni è lo stesso l'ho
vissuto sulla mia pelle e sono sicuro
l'abbiate vissuto anche voi
come ho detto È inutile concentrarsi su
mille idee obiettivi progetti di vita
allo stesso tempo perché per quanto
pensiamo di poter essere poliedrici
multitasking Non riusciremo mai a dare
tutti noi stessi per ognuno di quelli
Ecco quindi fate come Il piccolo
principe
dedicate alle vostre Rose il tempo che
meritano dedicate loro la vostra
passione
vi sentirete soddisfatti le renderete
uniche e chissà magari un giorno
cambierete pure il mondo
[Applauso]